hi everyone I'm here to talk to you
about webassembly like as Americo kindly
said I did race a car across the desert
I also flew on the Concord on frequent
flyer points so I had this obsession
with speeding which is why I love
webassembly it's fantastic and what you
need to understand is what it actually
is right it's a new capability for the
web it's a way that you can build really
high performance code and have it run
inside your web application it's also
not a replacement for JavaScript it
works alongside JavaScript so what it
enables you to do is to take things like
C++ and rust and compile it into what we
call a web assembly module or weather
module and you can load that into your
web application and call it from
JavaScript now when we were developing
this one of the things was speed right
it runs extremely fast it runs at a
small percentage slower than true native
code but more importantly it's very
secure so what weather means it's kind
of a binary format that was specifically
designed to be safer than JavaScript so
the instructions are very restricted
it's it's proven like there's a
mathematical proof in a published paper
about it so it actually adds there's a
whole security layer by design and on
top of that it runs inside chrome
sandbox so there are a couple of layers
of protection there for you when you use
it but probably a bigger goal was
portability so we wanted to enable the
compile once run everywhere model and so
it actually does run across a whole lot
of browsers so you might be wondering
what can you actually do with it well
say you already have a whole lot of
native code you might have a native app
that runs on desktop or even in an app
store and it could be written in C++ it
could contain business logic or you
could have a game engine that's also
like many many main years of invested
time so you could have a multi million
line codebase sitting out there in your
native application now you might think
about bringing that over into the web
now during the keynote yesterday there
was this whole talk of the new web
capabilities if you have a native app
you can now pull in the web browser
without the URL bar at the top which was
making the native app kind of or the web
more native like well web assembly is
the opposite end it's it's making your
web app more native like it actually
pull
in these native things so picture this
picture a new video format so we all use
various video formats as WebM as h.264
there's a whole literature of video
formats but if you were say a developer
that decided to come up with a whole new
codec or an eighth still image codec you
might want to deploy that across the web
now you could do two things you could
wait for the browser implementers to
actually implement it you could log a
bug against all the browsers saying
implement my new cool image format or my
new video format or you could just
compile your C++ code into a web
assembly module load it in your web app
and use that video format everywhere
without any changes hi I'm VP I'm a
software engineer and the web assembly
team so you've heard Alex talk about
what web assembly is why should you care
why is this relevant to you today so
more and more applications are moving to
the web you have audio decoders video
decoders game engines music applications
and a whole lot of other computation
intensive applications and we want these
to run at neo native speeds and not need
to be recompiled for each platform and
that's exactly what wasum gives you so
and that's exactly what was it gives you
and we have Chrome Firefox Safari edge
or support the first version of web
assembly and it in fact just shipped
shipped last week and we're very excited
about that so what are some of the big
companies that are using web assembly
right now this is a Jif of the Unity
game tanks we have a screenshot from the
epic Zen garden from the Unreal Engine
and so we want to take a little deeper
into why all of these companies use
plasm when you have a wiser module all
of the module information is encoded in
a dense binary format so what this means
is you have smaller but smaller binary
sizes you have faster loading faster
decoding
it's a smaller memory footprint and it's
just fewer bits over the wire so
everything is faster so one of the
things we want to do with this
presentation is to showcase a different
all of the variety of applications and
use cases that wasum works really well
for so website is demo it's a real-time
face detection demo of is a real-time
performance demo of face detection
algorithm that uses OpenCV for those of
you that are not familiar with open CV
open CV is the open version is the open
source computer vision library and it's
extensively used so let's switch to the
demo please so as you can see here what
we have is you have the webassembly
version which is open CV that's compiled
awasum running on the left side and on
the right side you have handwritten
JavaScript the performance is measured
by the amount of time it takes to detect
Alex's face in the video stream so as
you can see the wizened version is
currently at about 16 to 18 frames per
second and the JavaScript version is at
about 2 3 frames per second well we want
to show you here is that the Weizen
version is so much faster than the
JavaScript version can we switch to the
sides of these so like I said this is an
example of a large existing C C++ code
base that was compiled hawazin and
ported to run in the web and you can see
that these are significant performance
gains but the thing to bear in mind here
is that the handwritten JavaScript might
not actually be the fastest JavaScript
there is so the performance here might
be slightly inflated but you can still
see that the performance difference is
actually quite large if you want to
check out what is
actually available that's website s IG
HT so make sure you look for the right
thing okay so when we were getting this
talk ready I was trying to think of what
we could kind of show you to give you an
idea of what you could use web assembly
for so it's like you know we all build
websites right and so these days your
every web site is probably a megabyte or
so and 80% of that would likely be
images so I don't know about you but my
workflow is typically I'll take photos
with my camera or whatever and I'll pull
it into Photoshop and I'll crop and
tweak and then I'll adjust the quality
to try and get that image small because
you know we want to save bytes on the
wire we want to make our pages smaller
and part of that is optimizing your
images I don't know other people use
command-line tools you lose your
favorite things I thought what if we
could actually do that inside the
browser so what I did was I took the
independent JPEG group codec so this is
code that is in a lot of production
applications it's probably 20 years old
by now so it's had many many years of
debugging its rock-solid it ships in
production in fact a derivative of it is
inside blink to decode JPEG images but
we don't have a JPEG encoder in blink
right so what I thought is why don't I
just take the ijg code compile it into
like a module that I can then load that
module into my page and I can load
images and start playing with the
quality in size to see what happens so
step one which I encourage you all to do
is to download the Emscripten SDK and
install it on your workstation so once
you've installed it you will have a
bunch of command line tools that help
you work with the web assembly so this
is what I do to compile my little JPEG
transcoder it's nice and simple so AMC
sees the inscription C compiler now this
flag - s was an equals one tells the
compiler to generate a web assembly
module for me the next line which says -
s exported functions is JPEG transcode
exposes the C function jpg underscore
trans code to JavaScript
courtesy of web assembly so you can
actually put a list of functions in here
and export all of them the next line the
output is jpg squash J s so what that is
is
I'm script and generated glue codes so
that is JavaScript code that manages the
web assembly module for you so it
manages the interface it manages the
loading at man effect men like manages
all the calls in and out etc and then of
course is the last thing is my source
files jpg Transco dot c so once you've
done that on your command line it will
build you a javascript thing called jpg
squash j s and a web assembly module and
this is how you use it from your HTML so
the first thing you do is put in this
script tag which pulls in jpeg squash j
s now what this does is pulls in the web
assembly module hooks up all the glue
logic and creates a global object called
module and module is how you interface
to your web assembly so the code that I
actually write myself for you right as a
developer is something like this the
first thing I do is set a boolean saying
the web assembly is not loaded now the
reason I do this is because web assembly
modules are loaded as synchronously so
what happens is that when the first
script line is executed it kicks off the
load and then it kicks off the actual
compile so in the background the browser
is compiling the web assembly module to
machine code while the rest of your page
is continuing to load so they're running
in parallel now in a future version of
Chrome we're going to change is from
we're actually going to have streaming
compiled so as the weather module is
coming across the wire it will be
compiling at the same time which will
give you faster startup so I set this
property on the module object which is
on runtime initialized I set that to a
function and that function will be
loaded when my web assembly is ready and
so it just sets the boolean to say I can
use this stuff and so this is the simple
function I wrote to bash JPEGs so it
takes two arguments the source is a
typed array containing my original
compressed JPEG image the second
argument is the quality I'd like to
compress that down to so if the web
assembly is not loaded I just do nothing
if it's loaded I call this function JPEG
trance code which if you recall on the
previous slide I had in my exports so
this passes in the source typed array
the number of bytes that it is and the
quality I want to set it to and under
the covers that goes off to the C code
that's been compiled it decompresses the
JPEG image it
we compressors is that the new quality
and returns it inside that source typed
array and the return value from that
function is the number of bytes of the
newly compressed data now of course I
can't put a typed array on my page very
easily so what I need to do is convert
it to a blob URL so we pass in that type
array into this function make blob URL
which creates a blob URL tags it with
the mime type image JPEG and then I can
attach it to any image node or even put
it as a CSS background image so why
don't we just go to the demo and I'll
show you how this works okay so here's
the my beautiful UI the application that
I built and of course it's the
webassembly logo there so I could pick a
file so say I've taken a photo on my
camera I can just click the choose file
dialog which of course is being nice and
slow on me there we go so I'll just pick
this photo here's a photo of my daughter
and here i'm recompressing it at quality
5 so you can see the original image on
the left you can see if you compress it
to q5 on the right now if i just grab
the slider and bump it up to full
quality I'll kind of explain why I'm
doing this so this is 100% quality the
image is absolutely identical but it's
935 kilobytes remember when I mentioned
a megabyte for the typical web page I
don't want to deliver a megabyte so I
could like play binary chop or something
well let's go somewhere around the
middle so at 45 it's gone from 900 K to
100 K and still this image is still not
too bad like you can you almost can't
really tell in fact I can't really see a
lot of difference here I don't know
about you so let's go smaller again so
quality of 23 now it's probably not so
clear on the projector you can actually
see if there's there are a few bands in
the sky there but overall the faces is
still kind of recognizable the parrots
are happy you know I might just ship
this because the subject is clear the
skies a bit bad but I've only got 68
kilobytes now the reason I'm doing this
in the browser myself because I want to
actually hand up the
using my eyes to decide what it's going
to do because if you use an automatic
JPEG compression tool it will use things
like signal-to-noise ratio and decide to
deliver you an image that is
imperceptible from the original and
that's not what I want I want to deliver
less bytes over the wire so I'll just
show you one more image quickly so this
is an image that I took on Sunday with
my pixel two so this is a butterfly at
the California Academy of Sciences and
again I very compressed this at 23
quality which is what I was using for
the previous photo it's only 54 K but
you'll notice in this particular image
only the Center matters like there's
this butterfly it's in focus and over
the side here it's all blurry because
there's a lot of depth of field
happening so in fact I could even shrink
this even more so we have 50 K now and
I've experimented with this before I
went on stage so if you bump it down to
like say 10 that's still relatively
clear in the middle and you'll notice
the background here like you can see the
blur on the left and the blockiness on
the right well I don't care about that
blockiness you know so I can use my
better judgement to say well that's
blurred anyway I'll let it be blocky and
in fact this kind of gives it this
artistic look and then I only ship 37
kilobytes to my users okay so we flip
back to the slides please by the way if
you want me to open-source that just
ping me on Twitter and I'll happily
publish it okay so that's what one
person would do is a bit of fun right
yeah and something that I would do in my
day-to-day web workflow but now I wanted
to show you something that's a bit more
serious this is like a serious
engineering company building a large
product so what I'm gonna talk about is
this thing called construct 3 now what
this is it's an in browser game editor
so it's like a full-blown IDE but
running inside the browser
courtesy of web web assembly now what
they've done here is they've wrapped a
whole lot of public open source
libraries into an application that
combines the best of native and the best
of web and this is what I was talking
about earlier like the keynote may
improve native apps with web we're
actually improving web apps with No
if so what they bring into their
application they bring in a bunch of
open source libraries like they use
ffmpeg for video encoding and decoding
they use box 2d as a physics engine they
use Z Lib for compression they use PNG
crush to squash down their PNG images
but they're not just using native code
they're also using a lot of browser
capabilities so they're using HTTP -
they're using serviceworker they're
using WebGL - and they fall back to
WebGL one if it's not available they use
Web Audio for all their sound they even
use WebRTC and so this is a
full-featured
rich app and one thing that's really
really interesting about their web
experience is that the size of the thing
they load is smaller than their native
app now you think about that for a
minute because when they ship their
native app they have to compile all
those native libraries such as ffmpeg
etc etc but then they need to use the
functionality that's already built in
the browser so things like WebRTC like
compiling that alone is like
two-and-a-half Meg so that has to be put
into the native app but when it's on the
web they can actually load a smaller
payload and it actually loads a lot
quicker than their native app so can we
switch back to the demo please I'll just
show you what this thing does it's okay
so here is their IDE running inside the
browser like if there wasn't a URL bar
there you'd probably think this is like
you know Xcode or Visual Studio or
something like that
it's a full-featured web based game
editor so it has things like you know
there's the start page we have tree
controls here and you know proper tree
controls that work we have property
pages where this property page here
somewhere
so like property pages we even have like
a preview of the game that you're
working on like they're in the window
you have inspectors on the Left so at
the moment see it says press - to begin
I could just go over here to the tree
control and click on the text that's
displaying there and if I scroll down in
this inspector I've clicked multiple
things though they don't begin text then
we can actually see here's the text for
the press to begin I can just change
that to whole oh yeah chain
in my preview window or I can even go
into the editor like in my kind of
WYSIWYG mode and pull up a dialog box
and change it to something Oh
can't even spell and then we actually
change this live in our preview so this
is actually doing a lot of work in
webassembly and taking advantage of the
power of the browser so the people that
built construct 3 also have all these
great things like you can actually start
playing your game so you can mouse you
go hit play prepares preparing the
images packing the game and it pulls up
a new window running this thing so I can
actually start playing this game so I
can you know fly around and you know
start shooting things and as you can see
it's nice and performant because a lot
of the logic is actually in native code
running through web assembly module
which is very very nice now one of the
things that they've built with this IDE
is their they've got all the native code
that does all the magic and the editing
and the tree controls etc but they've
also used some of the best parts of the
web now what they've built is they built
this thing called remote preview and
what remote preview does is it creates
this QR code like I'm just gonna pull
out my phone and scan this QR code
quickly which gives me a URL which I can
click on if I click on that URL you'll
see it's connected to this client chrome
62 on Android right and what it's
actually doing is it creates yeah
excellent I was actually going to ask
you all to do that get your phones out
scan this QR code I'll leave that there
for a while I get everyone many of you
would want to do this as you can't see
ring crash the server I think if we try
hard enough we can keep going coming so
what this does is this actually takes
advantage of WebRTC really keep
scrolling it so where RTC has this thing
called a data Channel and that lets you
send arbitrary binary data around and so
in fact I just lose it know how many we
got 33 do you want to keep scrolling and
they slowed down
my load I'm only a ninety seven point
nine percent here people come on I'm
unloading the images anyway it allows
you to send binary data around the place
so they're in their IDE they've actually
built where bytes it's the data channel
to talk to your mobile device and then
send the web assembly modules across and
all the images and the entire game and
then you can start playing the game in
your phone straight from your IDE and
try it out so it's a very powerful
facility and hopefully some of you will
get it loaded in the minute and can play
can we go back to the slides please
so we've heard about projects that are
successfully using plasm right now if
we've heard about a whole bunch of these
demos and I want to talk about some
really exciting things that we're
working on for the future so first up we
have threads so the thread proposal
provides low-level building blocks for
pthread style shared memory between
threads or web workers in this case and
concurrency using Atomics and few taxes
so a lot of the existing native
libraries that are available extensively
use threads so adding threads to Adam so
simplifies porting multi-threaded
applications to the web and as a
developer this is functionality that you
can use in your applications you can
build multi-threaded applications and
you know have them work faster and
what's really exciting about this is
that this is coming soon we're actively
working on it and we should have
something for you to try by the end of
the end of the year and launch in the
first half of next year so because of
the nature of compilation targets
debugging in Bassem is not always easy
we have support for basic debugging but
we're actively working and adding source
Maps memory inspection and all of that
good stuff so it will make debugging
your application simpler and help with
figuring out exactly what's going on
with your application what are some of
the other features that were working on
we're working on adding Sindhi support
what does this mean
the means that we're adding support for
Wecht are instructions that I used in in
it video processing cryptography etc we
are also working on zero cast exception
handling so when you have C C++
applications that extensively use
exceptions what happens is that right
now we're emulating these using
JavaScript but that's not really fast so
we want to be able to provide a way for
these to work in a way that there's no
overhead so a lot of this presentation
we've been talking about C C++ libraries
but what about support for other
languages to do that we need garbage
collection we need to be able to
efficiently allocate and manipulate
managed objects directly from wasone
court and there's a proposal in progress
for adding GC support tourism so so far
you've seen a variety of applications
you've seen game engines you've seen
image detection compression modular
libraries but how big can this really
get how about the size of the earth
let's switch to the demo please okay so
you've seen a snippet of this in you've
seen a snippet of this in the keynote
yesterday but we want to show you what a
complex application like Google Earth
looks like in practice when it's using
wasum let's go to the Empire State
Building
you can see that this is a whole
immersive application you've got some
awesome 3d content you've got knowledge
cards that tell you what other
interesting sites are around so let's
try why Joe Weider is this really
interesting interesting application that
lets you explore different destinations
from around the world and I love
traveling so let's see what interesting
things we have here so unusual city
streets how about that so these are
curated map stories that are available
so let's go so let's see if this
actually brings up Street View and what
I want to point out here is that this is
using shaders WebGL API is you know and
seamlessly interfacing in and out of the
wasum runtime to give you this
incredible immersive experience one of
the criticisms about Google Earth when
it first came out was that it was chrome
only now let's pull this up in Firefox
and see what happens
we'll give it a second to load but what
we expect to see here is that this works
just as well in Firefox as well as a
dozen Chrome so to do an
apples-to-apples comparison let's look
for the Empire State Building again
so you've got like a very similar you
know the same 3d content everything
that's available in Chrome that's also
available in Firefox so you can see that
this works in a truly portable way
switch back to size please I also want
to give a shout out to our colleagues on
the earth team that have worked on
putting this to Azzam and made this such
a seamless experience they're here
Jordan and his team are here in person
so if you have any questions please feel
free to find them after the presentation
cool so what we kind of wanted to get
across here today especially for all the
web developers out there is web assembly
is ready now for primetime production
applications we're super excited to see
four major browser engines already
shipped this edge shipped last week so
we have edge Safari Firefox and of
course chrome shipping this now but also
something to keep in mind is that it's
not just desktop browsers it's a mobile
thing too so Safari on iOS 11 as well as
chrome on Android both support web
assembly so you can build highly
performant applications using native
code for mobile devices which of course
means faster execution time which means
less battery usage so this is why it's a
really exciting technology not just that
but not only the browser vendors but
there are other large companies working
with webassembly now so we've seen that
unity and epic are both using it so it's
a true game changer for the web we also
have autodesk releasing autocad using
web assembly so these large players are
using it because they realize this is
kind of a next-generation high
performance web application environment
and you should be taking advantage of it
too because using web assembly you'll
build better applications that will
delight your users thank you
[Music]